una sesión extraordinaria un 1o de enero
en un momento de máxima tensión entre
los republicanos del congreso y el
presidente dan al camp el senado
siguiendo la línea de la cámara de
representantes- desestimó por primera
vez un veto del mandatario con una
sonora mayoría a la cámara alta mantuvo
la ley de defensa a la que se oponía
trump el magnate argumentaba entre otras
cosas que esa normativa no limitaba la
actividad de algunas redes sociales a
las que el presidente acusa de ser
imparciales esta negativa desató una ola
de rechazo en el congreso que había
aprobado esa ley después de meses de
negociaciones entre republicanos y
demócratas es una responsabilidad grande
pero también es una oportunidad tremenda
para encaminar nuestras prioridades de
seguridad nacional de reflejar la
determinación del pueblo estadounidense
y las amenazas crecientes a su seguridad
tanto en casa como en el exterior
calificó como patético lo ocurrido e
insistió además en que el congreso
apruebe una cuantía mayor en la paga de
ayuda a los estadounidenses en medio de
la pandemia
se ha alineado con los demócratas
quienes defienden un cheque de dos mil
dólares por persona frente a los
seiscientos que buscan los republicanos
el senado tiene la última palabra sobre
ese asunto y de momento los republicanos
han aplazado la votación tal es el nivel
de crispación que el jueves trump
adelantó un día su vuelta de vacaciones
desde florida en la antesala de este
tira y afloja en el congreso